right now vice president kamala harris
back in her home state of california
after spending the day right here in las
vegas the i-team's david charns joining
us live in studio to tell us
about the vp's reason for a visit david
yeah so the president and the vice
president are basically crisscrossing
the country
selling that american rescue plan the
giant 1.9 trillion dollar spending
package that includes those stimulus
checks for most of us
the vice president starting her visit
here in las vegas with a stop
at the unlv vaccination site
i'm here to thank you on behalf of the
president myself
and our country for what you all are
doing i know it takes a lot out of you
we got light at the end of the tunnel
you've got the most amazing governor we
can imagine
the vice president starting her visit
with that stop there she chatted with
nursing and med
students and thanked them for all their
work she and her husband also visited
the culinary academy of las vegas where
the community
food assistance program has donated
nearly 13
million pounds of food during the
pandemic alone
the vice president speaking about how
the rescue plan benefits
students and union members there
including extended unemployment through
september
and also that child tax credit of three
thousand dollars
president biden you'll remember a while
back he said
help is on the way and then he signed
that american rescue plan so i would say
help is here help is here
help is here and as the congressman said
there are a number of things that it
does and so i'm here to also
make sure we get the word out now part
of the massive plan includes 4 billion
dollars coming right here to nevada
nearly 3 billion of that going to cover
the cost of the state budget which
itself
is about 4 billion every year republican
assemblyman tom roberts says he and his
colleagues now need to be mindful about
how they're going to spend it
the amount of money that we're getting
this time is probably more than enough
money which is why i believe
that we should shore up our rainy day
fund in case something like this happens
again we have a fourth wave or whatever
and it impacts tourism and
we shouldn't just continue to count on
the federal government to bail us out
and the national republican party saying
in part quote this massive 1.9 trillion
dollar stimulus bill has very little to
do with covert relief
and amounts to nothing more than a
progression a progressive
wish list that is according to the gop
well harris says the plan will bring 40
thousand children here in nevada out of
poverty
her visit comes as most businesses move
to that fifty percent capacity
and also as the clark county school
district gets more than eight hundred
million dollars in this new round of
funding
i'm david charn eight news now